[Music]
China has humiliated Biden in every way
imaginable first with their coveted
cover-up
shifting blame
will only cause needless delay in
response and distract us from the
overall objective China is a country
that delivers on its promises
then with their treatment of our
secretary of state in Alaska
the United States does not have the
qualification to say that it wants to
speak to China from a position of
strength that
there are many problems within the
United States regarding human rights
which is admitted by the U.S itself as
well the challenges facing the United
States in human rights are deep seated
oh Tony had to change his depends there
and then with their ongoing support of
Russia in the midst of the war in
Ukraine
and of course with the recent spy
balloon Saga
Factory
She's creepy and Biden's answer to all
this
thank you president XI may I have
another
well today our president made it clear
to China that they can literally do
almost anything to us and it will not
derail his overriding desire to get
closer to the CCP we are going to keep
our allies and the Congress
contemporaneously informed to all we
know and all we learn and I expect to be
speaking with President XI and I hope we
have come we are going to get to the
bottom list
yeah it definitely sounds vigorous there
pathetic the more Biden grovels the more
he shows weakness
the higher the price China will make our
country pay to stay in their good graces
China doesn't want to be our partner or
even our competitor
China wants to be our master
this white house though would rather
negotiate with President XI than
negotiate with Kevin McCarthy
on the debt ceiling the White House says
no negotiation no strings attached the
debt ceiling has to be raised
but they'll bend over backwards to
accommodate China's concerns and
interests on almost any issue
so how sick and twisted is this
meanwhile Biden tries to Peddle more
incredible excuses
my friends these guys in the
administration are either incompetent
corrupt or both
Biden needs to do something drastic to
regain even a shred of credibility
you know what's bad when even Mitch
McConnell is disturbed by what he's
hearing behind closed doors
we've been in these briefings as you
suggest but they don't seem to know
anything I've never been in briefings
where I learned so little
only because they're under intense
political pressure did the White House
decide to finally send Biden out to
address the nation today we don't yet
know exactly what these three objects
were but nothing nothing right now
suggests they were related to China's
spy balloon program or that there were
surveillance vehicles from other any
other country
now it might be the case that but why
should anyone reflexively believe any of
this
look Americans aren't stupid
they don't know what the other objects
were they say that so but they could
definitely say they're not Chinese what
because the Chinese tell us so
at the state department and the Pentagon
the mood is to accommodate
don't antagonize China
they want a relationship back on track
with China no matter what
if it weren't for the political
Firestorm at home blinken would never
have postponed his trip to China never
Vine is Biden's running on the same
Playbook that the China Lobby is used
for over two decades now
keep downplaying the threats and risks
from the CCP keep the business going
the longer Biden keeps carrying out
carrying the water for the CCP the
stronger China is going to get and the
stronger the populists are going to be
here at home
President Biden took an oath to uphold
the Constitution
his first and greater Duty and loyalty
has to be to our interests and our flag
not to fret about world Harmony my
secretary of state will lead an effort
to help establish a global a global
common Global norms and this largely
unregulated space
these steps will lead to safer and more
secure skies for our air Travelers our
military our scientists and for people
on the ground as well
anytime Biden tries to justify the
unjustifiable he invokes the need to
satisfy a global order in this case
Global norms
now whether it's his Vendetta against
fossil fuels or a proxy war in Ukraine
the sacrifice Americans are asked to
make is for the benefit of the
International Community it's
it's never for the benefit of the people
around them in their own neighborhoods
we don't need Global rules in order to
stop other countries from flying spy
aircraft overhead we need smart strong
leadership starting at the top
so here's my message to Biden stop
trying to be China's friend start trying
to be America's friend
then maybe the people you're supposed to
be looking out for will actually give
you the benefit of the doubt when you
know what hits the fan hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else